sudan's military and civilian leaders
have reached a deal to reinstate the
ousted prime minister abdallah hamduk he
was forced out in a coup nearly a month
ago the army says hamduck will lead a
new independent cabinet but the main
opposition grouping the forces of
freedom and change says it won't
recognize any deal with the military
for more than three weeks sudan has been
rocked by protests
some of them deadly
[Music]
the unrest follows a military coup
headed by general abdel fattah burhan
derailing the promised move towards
democracy
political opponents were detained
and prime minister abdallah hamdok was
placed under house arrest
[Applause]
sudan is no stranger to kuz in 2019 the
veteran president omar al-bashir was
overthrown by the army he'd ruled for
more than 30 years
[Music]
but it seems these latest anti-coup
protests have unsettled the military
abdallah
they promise will be reinstated as prime
minister
the main opposition though says it won't
recognize any government that involves
the army
[Applause]
let's take a look at these latest
developments with khalid kai are their
think tank inside strategy partners
she's in the sudanese capital
hello so sudan's main civilian
opposition coalition is not in favor of
this new agreement why
well i mean first of all i think it's
important to note that very few people
are in favor of this new agreement for
the ffc the
body that you mentioned
they've been completely sort of left
behind they say from any negotiations
and for some of them their stance has
been not to negotiate in the first place
with the military because they know that
any agreement arising from a negotiation
with the military at the moment will
result in senior military leadership
remaining in power and that's not
something that they all their
constituents want um my sense is that
this current agreement which of which we
know very few details is probably not
satisfying to them either in terms of
the political dispensation that they
will have
so then who is the big loser in this
latest power struggle
i mean
the whole country i suppose is a loser
in some sense because
the uh the crisis is having manifold um
impact on different facets of society
particularly the young uh people who are
dying on the streets every day through
regime violence and so any um
any sort of talk of uh
an agreement right now that doesn't take
into account
the voices on the street the forces of
different facets of society particularly
among young people who make up the
overwhelming population of sudan isn't
going to be sort of dead in the water
before it's even been inked
so what do these developments tell us
about where sudan is heading
it's difficult to say because it's such
a fluid situation you know from one day
to the next we're hearing there's an
agreement being um brokered by either an
international or even a domestic group
of people but the issue is that you know
that the military will say that it is
considering or entertaining some of
these offers but in the meantime they
seem to be using it to buy time so that
they can put in place um the sort of uh
you know either the appointments or the
mechanisms in place for them to stay on
even longer and the reason they're doing
that is because the coup in and of
itself is pretty weak so they're hoping
that time will be a factor that will
allow them to to stay in and empower as
much as possible of course that is only
going to rile up not just the street but
even the political elites who two years
ago compromised on an agreement and that
saw the power sharing deal had and so
people are learning the lessons of 2019
and by and large projecting anything any
kind of political arrangement that sees
members senior members of the army but
also of the islamists that back them in
government okay
thank you very much for your insights
thank you